Find a good company name and product name.
The names you choose for your company and products are what people remember you by.
If they're too hard to pronounce, difficult to spell or not easy to recall,...
...then you lose out on the opportunity of having customers talk about you to their friends,...
...and coming back as repeat buyers.
Sony's original company name was Tokyo Tsushin Kogyo Kabushiki Kaisha.
Long and difficult to remember in English,...
...the company decided it would need to change its name...
...to better serve the North American market.
Trying to find a new name, Morita found that "sonus" is the Latin word for "sound."
He thought its meaning was appropriate considering their industry.
However, he didn't think that it was catchy enough.
Morita decided to combine "sonus" with "Sonny,"...
...a nickname that had become popular amongst American kids.
Morita thought "Sonny" would help portray the image of the company as a youthful one,...
...with lots of energy and bright future ahead.
With that, the Sony Corporation was formed.